direkt einmal vorweg die frage wir haben
es gerade auch von karl heim gehört über
diese sekte und vor allem über diese
eltern in dieser sekte da ist eben
bekannt dass die eigenen kinder
geschlagen werden dass die kinder in
dunkle räume gesperrt werden was sind
das für menschen und vor allem was sind
das für eltern
ja man könnte meinen dass es besonders
brutale menschen sind die sich der
gemeinschaft der zweigstellen schließen
aber das ist nicht so es handelt sich um
besonders idealistische menschen die
hohe ethische prinzipien haben die eine
bessere welt schaffen
möchten und die dann von der
gemeinschaft der zwölf stämme zu hören
bekommen diese bessere welt kommt dann
wenn wir eine reine generation auf
ziehen die kinder müssen allein sein und
das heißt dass sie gehorchen müssen
absoluten gehorsam sie dürfen keinen
eigenen willen mehr haben und dann wird
gewährt nur durch diese züchtigung
erreichen wir dass wir den eigentlichen
erbrechen können also ethische menschen
werden zu einem verhalten angeleitet das
nach gemein gesellschaftlicher
auffassung komplett ohne dich ist das
eine umwertung der werte aus gut wird
böse und diese perversion der werte die
ist für sekten ganz typisch es gut wird
böse ein ganz wichtiger satz jetzt haben
wir gehört dass in den letzten jahren
rund 40 kinder aus dieser sekte
rausgeholt wurden weil sie eben in
dieser sekte geschlagen wurde wurden was
ist in der in der folge dann passiert
hat die sekte probiert diese kinder
zurück zu bekommen wie ist das von sich
gegangen ja das ist so heran durch
juristische schritte haben die
mitglieder die betroffenen eltern
versucht ihre kinder wieder zurück zu
halten das ist eine hälfte der fälle
auch schon gleich gewesen also nun die
hälfte dieser kinder ist wieder bei der
gemeinschaft die andere hälfte ist nach
draußen zum teil auch weil die eltern
inzwischen ausgestiegen sind also halb
erfolgreich und das jetzt gerade an
kindern führt wird dass ich mich auch
nach typisch weil der gründer der zwölf
stämme dieser albert hughes kriegs hat
gelehrt dass die gemeinschaft der zwölf
stämme 50 jahre aktiv sein wird und dann
kommt jesus wieder und wird die kinder
als die reine generation dann als seine
braut entgegen also dann kam die endzeit
50 jahre nach der gründung und dann
müssen die kinder bereitstellen
gegründet wurde die gemeinschaft
1972 also und zwar im nächsten jahr 20
22 erwartet die gemeinschaft dass jesus
wieder konnte dann müssen die kinder
bereit stehen also dieser antrieb jetzt
die kinder wieder zurückzunehmen ist
sehr stark und ich halte deshalb weitere
entführungen nicht für ausgeschlossen
das ist ja total spannendes und
wichtiges detail also in dieser sekte da
glaubt man dass man in eine neue zeit in
eine endzeit aufbricht die würde dann
2022 beginnen und deswegen ist es
natürlich dann womöglich wichtig wenn
ich in dieser sekte lebe und daran
glaube mein eigenes kind dann bis
dorthin wieder bei mir zu haben und
zurück zu haben ganz genau weil die
kinder die reihen ausgezogen und kinder
sind so der eintrittspreis sind diese
heile welt in dieser ideale welt in
dieses paradies und deshalb ist der
antrieb sehr stark jetzt die kinder
zurückzuholen um dann im nächsten jahr
bereit zu sein wenn jesus wieder kommt
herr schmidt sie haben vorhin
angesprochen einige aussteiger dazu
abschließend eine frage wie schwer ist
es menschen aus dieser sekte
herauszuholen und wie schwer ist es dann
für diese menschen im ich sag mal echten
leben anzukommen und hier dann auch
lieben zu können der ausstieg aus in
zwölf ständen ist besonders schwierig
weil man da ja zusammen lebt man
arbeitet doch dazu wäre besser kleine
wohnsitz mehrere hat keine arbeitsstelle
mehr all das muss die die person die aus
steigt wieder neu
erhalten also da braucht auf jeden fall
hilfe unterstützung wenn wir angehörige
haben in den zwölf stellen ist das beste
was wir tun können wenn wir den kontakt
bleiben weil diejenigen personen den
volksstämmen die nach kontakt haben zu
stehen kommen leichter als wenn er nach
leichter den einstieg wieder in die
gesellschaft besonders schwierig ist für
kinder in den zwölf stämmen aufgewachsen
sind weil sie ja das leben in unserer
gesellschaft eigentlich gar nicht kennen
die müssen dann das leben in unserer
gesellschaft ihre werte ihre
vorstellungen und ihre errungenschaften
ganz neu kennen das ist ein jahrelanger
prozess ist das funktioniert
daneben
[Musik]